I was standing outside and I I I bummed
a cigarette off Freddy and we were
standing out there being very naughty
and smoking and this couple came out and
the the woman came over to me she said
thank you so much for that I I really
you know it's really changed the way I
think about things particularly about
children I never thought about children
never thought that's what I
wanted but but this is what I want now
and I said how old are you and she said
43 wow
and I hope to God that they're able to
to have a child and and get what they
want but the truth is that's
unlikely there are many many people who
are in that position in our world um
who've
been look I said brainwashed maybe it
was the wrong word but who've been
encouraged to forget about the things
that actually matter